RYAN LOREN: Darien, thanks a
lot for being here, man.
DARIEN: Thank you
for having me.
RYAN LOREN: It's been a long
time coming, and I'm happy to
have you here.
DARIEN: Absolutely happy
to be here, man.
RYAN LOREN: Just wanted to have
a quick chat before the
performance.
So just real quick, tell us
about yourself-- where you
come from, your heritage, and
what Black History Month means
to you, because this
is a celebration of
Black History Month.
DARIEN: Absolutely.
Well, my name is Darien Dean.
I'm an independent solo artist
out of Mount Vernon, New York.
It's a great time to be an
independent artist, especially
one who has message-driven
music.
And during Black History Month,
I have an opportunity
to really, really showcase some
of the message music that
I'm putting forth.
So right now, I'm in the process
of working on a new
record, "Notes From The
Journey." But my previous
record, "If These Walls Could
Talk," had a song called "Love
Revolution." And I was able to
really tour with that song and
move throughout the country with
it, really, and really
not just have it be a month but
have it be something that
is a lasting effect and
goes wherever I go.
So it's nice to have the month
to focus, but for me it's a
constant journey.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
And that's good to hear.
And what's the new album
going to be called?
DARIEN: "Notes From
The Journey."
RYAN LOREN: "Notes From
DARIEN: Indeed.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
All right, you've been
on indie scene.
I wanted to ask you--
there's so many talented
people in
New York and overall--
what separates those who have
the talent but those who get
more exposure, those who
are more successful?
What's going on out there?
What separates the good
from the better?
DARIEN: It's crazy, because
there are a lot of talented--
I see you on a regular-- we're
out and on the scene and
seeing the talent that's
out there.
So it's not necessarily
something that's split via the
talent at this point.
There's a lot of political stuff
going on in all areas of
music, not just independent
music.
I think the artists that hustle
the most-- and by that
I mean they're consistent and
they're working and putting
out the best product
that they can--
eventually do get a bit of a
foothold and move forward.
But I think we're still at a
space where we do need some
tastemakers with a little bit
more power to step up and make
some moves for these artists
because, I always say, if I've
got to step out of the kitchen,
I can't cook.
And that becomes part of the
issue in being an independent
artist, is that you have to
juggle so many things--
be good at your craft but at the
same time go out there and
now do this hustle.
And there's a myriad of
musicians at this point, and
that actually makes it
difficult as well.
RYAN LOREN: Definitely.
So can you describe your music
for those who might not know
about you that are going to be
watching and are here tonight?
DARIEN: Indeed.
Well, my music is an
amalgamation of all the things
that I've come across.
I started off as a dancer.
I was a choreographer, and
I was deep into hip-hop--
so definitely have those
hip-hop roots that
are infused in there.
I've been traveling.
The musicians that I play with,
they range from church
musicians to jazz musicians.
So they add their flavor.
But at the end of the day, I'm
really into the craft of
songwriting, so I try to present
stories, hence the
titles, "If These Walls Could
Talk," "Notes From The
Journey." Most of my songs are
stories about life that I've
either come into contact with
people and had discussions or
my own life.
So that's pretty much the range
but, again, infused with
a bit of hip-hop and
a bit of a jazz and
fusion kind of thing.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Yeah, and I think when I first
heard your album title for the
first one, it actually evokes
an image in my head.
DARIEN: It's a visual,
for sure.
RYAN LOREN: And I think that's
really cool that that's how
you approach things.
So we're at Google, so I'd like
you to talk a little bit
about technology.
I know you're a techie.
[LAUGHTER]
DARIEN: Well, you know
I'm a techie.
I'm into this.
This is my thing.
So technology has been really
helpful in my journey.
And I didn't get into
it after the fact.
I'd always been.
But it just helps so
much in what we do.
As an independent musician,
you're always fighting a
budget battle.
It's always a budget thing.
So the more that you're able to
do on your own, the better
it is for your pocket.
So in doing things like mixing
the album, I have my own
set-up, and we do that kind
of thing at the house.
For instance with Google Tools,
some the things that I
do, there was a point where I
was writing songs on random
pieces of paper everywhere.
And I just could never find them
and piece them together.
And even later on, I got into
something where I was writing
songs on my laptop.
But I might not have it with me,
so now I'm doing something
here or there.
One of the things that I use
now is Google Drive.
And I actually write songs that
I'm able to get into the
cloud and basically add to them
from wherever I am-- my
phone, my iPad, whatever.
So those are the kind
of things that help
me get things done.
I find myself writing faster,
and I find myself getting my
ideas out more clearly because
I'm not looking for the scrap
and going, I know there's a
good scrap here somewhere.
That's where I'm at sometimes
with it, so it's been really
helpful, absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah, and I know,
as a songwriter, you never
know when you're going
to get that idea.
DARIEN: You never know.
RYAN LOREN: So if you have the
phone and it all syncs, then
it works out really well.
DARIEN: Absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
I'm glad to hear it.
I just wanted to thank you
again for being here.
You have the album coming out.
When should we expect that?
DARIEN: As an independent
artist, I don't
have the exact date.
That's how it goes.
But I will say I'm really,
really amped
about the new project.
I have some incredible people
working on it with me.
And I've been able to, I feel,
really build off the last
record and build my
skill set even.
And so I can't wait
to present it.
I'm really excited about that.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well we're really excited to
have you here and can't wait
for the performance, and I
wish you all the best.
And thanks for your
honest music.
DARIEN: Thank you
once again, man.
RYAN LOREN: All right, man.
DARIEN: [INAUDIBLE].